one place that people are not really
talking about and it goes a long way to
explaining why Republicans couldn't
quite put it over the edge in New York
why they couldn't really get it done in
Pennsylvania why nothing really happened
in California why Florida was just so
overwhelmingly Republican why Texas had
an extremely good night for republicans
and that is that people have voted with
their feet I'm one of the people who
voted with my feet I moved out of new
Cellini's hellscape of California came
to the free state of Tennessee which is
fabulous and a lot of other people did
that to Tennessee and Texas and
especially Florida but one of the
consequences of voting with your feet is
then you don't vote at The Ballot Box in
the state that you left and it becomes
harder for Republicans to win so that's
another macro trend of the night that
you can't just blame on Trump or just
give credit to some other candidate for
you have to say that's a macro Trend in
politics where it's yes Republicans are
going to do better in the red States the
red states are going to get redder but
that means the blue states are going to
get Bluer it's gonna be harder to have
those purple kinds of wins